The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANDREW LO: What I
want to do today
is to continue where we left
off last time in talking
about the capital
asset pricing model,
and we're going
to finish that off
in the next 15 or 20 minutes.
And then, I'm going to turn
to applications of the capital
asset pricing model.
In particular, I want to
focus on capital budgeting.
That's going to be the
last major topic we take on
for this course.
So let me finish the
capital asset pricing model
and then I'll talk a
little bit about where
we're going to go for the
remainder of the lectures.
You remember last time
where we left off was,
I decided to estimate the
CAPM relationship for a couple
of stocks, Biogen and Motorola.
And we found that the estimated
alphas, the deviations
from the CAPM,
were pretty sizable
for both of these companies.
And the interpretation
is either,
wow these companies are
really exceptional values,
they offer investors
much, much larger
expected return than justified
by the appropriate market
betas.
That's one interpretation,
or the other interpretation
is there something
missing with the CAPM.
The CAPM doesn't
quite capture all
of the risks that are giving
you these kinds of expected
rates of return.
So I'm going to come
back to that debate
in just a few minutes.
But I thought, that to continue
along these lines, let's
explore a little bit
about the goodness of fit
of these measures.
Now, I mentioned last
time that the R-squareds,
as a measure of goodness of
fit, was 17.5 percent for Biogen
and 33% for Motorola.
Both of which are
reasonably representative
of the kind of goodness
of fit measures
that you're going to
see with financial data,
for the simple reason that
financial data is very noisy.
And so you're not going to
get any single theory that
can explain 99.9 percent
of the fluctuations
in any kind of financial series.
So here's a plot of
Biogen versus the market.
Now the market, as I
reminded you last time,
is the valuated
return, including
dividends, of all stocks on
the NYSE, Amex, and NASDAQ.
So this market
portfolio, you can
think of as being a broader
version than the S&P 500,
but it's meant to
capture the market.
So this is a plot of
Biogen versus the market.
And you can see that
there is some slope that
fits this scatter of points,
and of course the equation
is 1.42 times the market,
minus a particular value
for the alpha, and then
R-squared of about 33%
over this particular
sample period.
So there is a line that
goes through these points,
but it's not a perfect
straight line by any means.
You can see there's a scatter.
And so there's a
tendency for Biogen
to move together
with the market,
but it's not a perfect linear
relationship by any means.
That's why the
R-squared is not 100%.
It's because we're not able to
explain all of the fluctuations
with a simple
linear relationship.
Life is more
complicated than that,
and so the CAPM is really
just an approximation
to a much more complex reality.
Now, a particular stock has
a lot of idiosyncratic risk.
That's what we talked about
last time as the dancing
the Irish jig on that
catwalk when you're window
washing on these skyscrapers.
So you can see that that
idiosyncratic risk is really
quite significant.
What happens if we plot, not
Biogen against the market,
but another market portfolio
against the market.
like let's say NASDAQ.
Well, the next plot shows you.
Look at NASDAQ versus
the market as a whole.
Now NASDAQ, as you know, tends
to have smaller stocks, stocks
that seem to be technology
oriented, and as a result
NASDAQ might be more volatile.
But nevertheless, there is a
very strong common relationship
between these two
market indexes.
And so now, look at this.
Scatter of points
is a lot tighter.
Right?
Still, it's not exactly linear,
but comparing this to that,
you can see the difference.
Right?
There was a stronger
relationship here.
And not surprisingly,
when you put securities
into a portfolio, what
gets averaged out?
AUDIENCE: Outliers.
ANDREW LO: Exactly, the
outliers, and what else?
What other component?
Leland.
AUDIENCE: The
idiosyncratic risk.
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
The Idiosyncratic
risk, The unusual stock
specific kinds of randomness
that gets averaged out.
So not surprisingly,
when you put things
into portfolios the noise, or
the idiosyncratic risks average
out and what you're left with is
whatever common factors remain.
So I'm going to show you
some evidence for how well,
or how poorly the
CAPM works by looking
not at individual
stocks, because we
know there's a lot of noise
with individual stocks.
I want to show you what
happens when you put stocks
into portfolios and you look
at how those portfolios do.
So let's do one simple
example, market cap portfolios.
Let's take a look at small
stocks and big stocks.
Remember at the introduction
of this series of lectures,
I showed you some
empirical evidence
that illustrated the fact
that small stocks seem
to do really well relative to
large stocks, the size anomaly.
So let's now take
the size anomaly
and look at it through
the lens of the CAPM
and ask the question,
with the CAPM
can we explain the difference
between small and large?
OK.
Well, let's take a look.
Over the 40 years
from 1960 to 2000,
approximately, we see that
the small stock portfolio,
the smallest decile, the
smallest tenth of stocks,
in terms of market cap, as
a group, as a portfolio,
had an average monthly return
of 1.33% and a beta of 1.4.
On the other hand, the
large stock portfolio
had an average monthly return
of 0.9% and a beta of 0.94.
So that seems like it's
sort of consistent.
Lower risk, lower expected
return, but let's plug it in
and see if the CAPM relationship
actually can tell us something.
So the expected return of the
stock, according to the CAPM,
is going to be given by the
risk free rate, plus beta,
multiplied by the market risk
premium over the sample period
that I'm looking at.
The market risk premium is about
a half a percent per month.
So roughly 6% a year.
And the risk free rate is
also about a half a percent
per month during
this time period.
So now, let's ask
the question, what
is the expected return of
a large stock portfolio?
Well according to
this, it should
be 93 basis points per month.
What about the small
stock portfolio?
According to this, it
should be 1.16% per month.
Now, this is an
amazingly good fit,
so I wouldn't take this
as typical in the finance
literature.
But it just so happens that
over this 40 year period,
the CAPM actually
works pretty darn well.
0.99 is the average
realize return and 0.93 is
what was predicted.
For the small cap portfolio,
1.33 is what was realized
and 1.16 was what was predicted.
So that's pretty good.
Now, I want to
emphasize the point
that this is really
good because, let's take
a look at other ways of
dividing up the universe
and seeing whether or not we
can get a better explanation
of risk and expected return.
Here's a picture of size sorted
portfolios along the security
market line.
So remember,
security market line
is a graph of beta
and expected return.
Right?
The security market line
applies to all portfolios
and securities, unlike
the capital market
line that applies only
to efficient portfolios
and securities.
So in this case, we expect
a linear relationship.
And with the exception of
this little outlier up here.
From 1960 to 2001
there was actually
a pretty reasonable relationship
between beta and expected
return.
In other words, the CAPM looks
like it's actually doing OK
for size sorted portfolios.
The higher the beta, the
higher the expected return.
The lower the beta, the
lower the expected return
for size sorted portfolios.
Now, what about for
beta sorted portfolios?
Suppose you took a
bunch of portfolio
and grouped them into beta's
and asked the question,
do the high beta portfolios
have higher expected return?
Low betas have low
expected return?
It turns out that, again you
get a reasonable relationship.
Not exactly what ' would
expect according to the CAPM.
So the slope of
this line, remember,
is going to be given by the
risk premium, the market risk
premium.
In fact, the realized
relationship looks linear,
but it's at a slightly
different slope.
It doesn't look like the risk
premium is the right slope,
something a little
bit less than that
seems to be the right slope.
And it turns out that
in 15.433, you're
going to learn a new
theory of the CAPM
that was developed by Fisher
Black called the Balck CAPM.
And the Black CAPM says that
there is no risk-free rate.
In fact, what you
ought to be using
is the rate of return of
something called a zero beta
portfolio.
Well it turns out that if you
do that, you would actually
get a line that fits
this line almost exactly.
So the Black
Zero-Beta CAPM seems
to be a better approximation,
but for now the CAPM
is actually a pretty
reasonable first approximation,
so let's finish off that first
and I'll come back to the Black
Zero-Beta CAPM in a minute.
OK.
So this is a plot of
the expected return
of beta sorted portfolios.
Higher beta, higher
average return.
Lower beta, lower
So it seems like a CAPM is
actually pretty reasonable.
I'm not perfect, but
it gets at the heart
of what risk really means.
Now in order to
emphasize the point,
let me show you a
couple of other graphs.
This is volatility
sorted portfolios.
So now, I'm sorting stocks based
upon their total volatility,
not just their beta.
Remember, the beta measures a
part of their total volatility.
Right?
The beta is the systematic
component of the risk.
Volatility is the entire
amount of risk of a security.
If you use volatility as
a way of sorting stocks,
then look at the
expected rate of return.
There is no systematic
relationship
between volatility and return.
The higher the volatility,
you don't get necessarily the
higher the return.
So in other words, volatility
is not the right measure
of the risk reward trade-off.
One of the first things I talked
to you about in this course
is that, if we've learned
anything in modern finance
we've learned that you don't
get something for nothing,
and in particular, if you
are gonna bear more risk,
you have to be paid
to bear more risk,
but you have to define
risk appropriately.
In this case this diagram
shows that volatility is not
the right measure of risk.
You might have to bear more
volatility for whatever reason,
but you won't
always get rewarded.
Right?
Because volatility is
not the relevant measure
of risk from the capital
markets point of view.
What you get rewarded for is
the risk that you cannot get rid
of by diversification and that
kind of risk is not sigma,
it's beta.
So beta, you do get rewarded.
Sigma, you do not get
rewarded necessarily.
Right?
Higher risk does not
mean necessarily higher
expected rates of return
when you measure risk
with volatility.
Higher risk in the
form of beta does
seem to be associated
with higher
expected rates of return.
OK.
Now, in the most
recent literature
there have been-- oh, question?
AUDIENCE: So if I remember the
definition of volatiility--
or based [INAUDIBLE],,
it's a ratio of two
standard deviations, right?
ANDREW LO: Beta is the ratio of
a covariance to the variance.
It's not the ratio of
standard deviations.
In the case of an
efficient portfolio,
it's the ratio of two
standard deviations.
Other questions?
OK.
So what I'm going
to tell you now
is about the most
current research.
The most current
research suggests
that, while beta does seem to
have some impact on explaining
expected returns, there
are other factors out there
that seem to contribute
to that explanation.
In other words, the
CAPM, while it's
a very interesting and
compelling first approximation,
it is only an approximation.
There are other factors,
like book to market,
like liquidity,
like trading volume,
that seems to also add
to the explanatory power
of these kinds of relationships.
So what we're at
today is that we
think there are multiple
betas out there, not just
one market beta.
So the basic vanilla
flavored theory of finance,
and what you're going to
be learning how to use over
the next few lectures
remaining in this course,
is the single beta CAPM.
But where we are at the
cutting edge of research,
or some would argue the
bleeding edge of research,
is that there are multiple betas
out there, multiple sources
of common risk.
So it's not just
the market risk,
that is by far the biggest,
but there is liquidity risk,
there is currency risk,
there is term structure risk,
there is a variety of risks that
cannot be diversified away with
a large portfolio of very,
very different kinds of assets.
And So a better version
of the CAPM, one
that you might use if you are
becoming an expert in finance
theory, is to try to identify
other sources of betas,
other sources of expected
return that have risks attached
to them and to use
these multiple factors
in your analysis.
So these are some references
that you can take a look at,
but the fact is that the CAPM
is used, almost universally,
among portfolio managers, among
venture capitalist, and project
managers, and chief
financial officers.
So the CAPM is a very,
very powerful framework
for thinking about
risk and return.
And so it's important to
understand it, but just
keep in mind that like
any other finance theory
it's just a theory, its just
meant to be an approximation
to a much more complex reality.
So what we're going to do now--
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Would the
other betas always have
to be associated with
like some kind of market
portfolio or some
representative portfolio,
or do they just track
a defaulted [INAUDIBLE]
or something like that.
ANDREW LO: So that's a great
question, let me repeat that.
The question is, does factors
that are useful for the CAPM
always have to be
associated with some kind
of a tradable market
portfolio, or index,
or can it be some other
factor, like macroeconomic like
unemployment?
Well, there's a big
difference between factors
that are economically
relevant and factors
that are financially
relevant, and let
me explain the difference.
Factors that are
economically relevant
may well explain the returns
of certain securities.
A good case in point
is unemployment.
Unemployment is a
factor that does
seem to have some explanatory
power for stock market returns.
The reason that we don't focus
on those kinds of factors
from a financial decision
making point of view
is that while they may
identify interesting economic
relationships between
certain parts of one
part of the economy and
other, it doesn't really
allow you to make any
kind of market decisions.
In other words, if
you can't trade it,
then you can't manage it.
So from the perspective
of financial applications,
most of the factor
models that you will see
are factor models
where the risk factors
are portfolios of securities,
or in some other sense tradable
So for example, if I had a
particular beta exposure--
For example, if I'm holding
a portfolio over here
and this is more
beta than I want,
I can get rid of that beta
by trading in S&P futures
contracts to decrease the beta.
You can't trade unemployment.
All right?
At least not as easily as
you could market beta's.
So while there are many
research papers out there that
try to document the
relationship between all sorts
of economic indicators
and financial markets
from the applications
perspective the kind of models
that we will be
dealing with will
be factors that are
associated with portfolios
of marketable securities
that you can trade,
purely from a
practical perspective.
OK.
So the key points for
these series of lectures,
lectures 15 through 17, what
I want you to take with you
is that there are two
critical relationships
that you must understand.
The first, is the risk reward
trade for efficient portfolios,
that's the capital market line.
And the second, is the
risk reward relationship
for all other kinds of
portfolios, that's the security
market line of the CAPM.
The CAPM.
requires equilibrium.
That's a departure
from everything
we've done in this
course up until now.
All of the pricing
relationships that I've argued
have to hold things like
present values of bonds,
of stocks, of futures,
of forwards, of options,
all of those pricing
models, all of them,
rely just on this
notion of no free lunch,
that people prefer more
money to less money.
But with the CAPM,
I actually had
to invoke a much
stronger condition.
I actually had to require
that supply equals demand.
It was through supply
equaling demand
that I was able to identify
that the tangency portfolio is
equal to the market portfolio.
OK?
So what we've done is to look
into the heart of the market
and try to infer from that
what the market is actually
doing by coming up with a
particular discount rate that
is consistent with
those market views.
And that now provides us with
a complete theory of finance
from your perspectives.
You now know how to value 99.9%
of anything that's out there,
you've got the tools to do that.
So what I want to do with
the remainder of the course
is I'm going to
force you to apply
those tools In several
different contexts
until you understand
how the tools work.
OK?
So that's a we're going to do
for the rest of the course.
Let me just pull
up the syllabus.
Amazingly, we're actually on
schedule despite the crisis
and all our discussions thereof.
We are to be focusing on capital
budgeting today, next lecture,
and the third
lecture, where we take
the tools of net present
value calculations and risk
adjustments and
then just apply them
to a bunch of
different contexts.
We're going apply
them left and right.
And what I'd like to do after
that is to put it all together.
In the very last
lecture I'm going
to try to give you a
sense of where we stand
today in terms of how to apply
these tools more broadly given
the market conditions
that prevail.
So I'm going to talk
about market efficiency
versus behavioral
finance, psychology
and I'm going to
bring in some evidence
from the cognitive
neurosciences that
will integrate all of the
different parts of the course.
So make sure if you're going
to come for one lecture,
you're going to
come to that one,
because that's where I'm going
to put it all together for you.
OK.
So we're going to turn now
to this notion of capital
budgeting.
I'm going to take the
perspective that we now
understand how markets work.
We understand how
pricing works, we
know how to make
risk adjustments,
and we're going to
take those ideas
and apply them to very
practical settings.
And so in that respect
I'm going to ask
you to change your focus.
Up until now we've
been looking at markets
from the perspective of
an investor, either Warren
Buffett, or the investor that's
steeped in portfolio theory.
Now, I want you to
change your perspective
and say that you are a
corporate financial officer,
or you're a project
manager and you're
trying to make
financial decisions
about various
different alternatives.
You're not principally
trying to beat the market,
or you're not principally
trying to invest you're wealth,
you're trying to make a
decision about whether
or not to take on
certain projects.
And the question is, how do
we use the tools that we've
developed to do that?
So we're going to start
with the NPV rule, which
is the rule that we've
developed at the very beginning
of this course.
It's very appropriate
that we end the course
with a discussion on
this rule, but now
with a much more sophisticated
understanding of how
to apply it.
I'm going to talk about
cash flow computations
because it will turn out that
cash flows are what you need
to discount with NPV, not
accounting earnings which
have all sorts of conventions
that are not necessarily
realistic, or relevant for
economic decision making,
but rather I want you to focus
on actual dollars and cents
that you're going to be
getting period by period.
I'm going to talk
about discount rates
and applying them over
time, project interactions,
alternatives to the NPV role,
and how capital budgeting is
currently done.
There are going to be
three different main points
to this sequence of lectures.
The first main point is to
use proper risk adjustments
in doing NPV calculations.
That's something
that I think by now
should be already ingrained
in your way of thinking,
but I want to make
sure that that's true.
The second main point
I want to get across
is that, there are lots of
different ways of doing capital
budgeting, but in
this case there's
only one right way to do
it from the perspective
of economic analysis.
Now, economic analysis may
not be the only consideration.
When you make a decision about
whether to take on a project,
there are economic
considerations,
but there are also political,
social, practical, cultural,
all sorts of other
considerations.
I'm not going to say anything
about those because that's
outside the purview of
this finance course,
but from the business
and financial decision
making perspective, NPV is
always the right thing to do
and I want to emphasize that
by showing you three wrong ways
of doing capital budgeting.
These are ways that people
still will make use of today.
So things like using
IRR, or using payback,
or using profitability indexes.
I'm going to go
through each of those
and argue why those are not
the correct way of making
financial decisions,
but because they're
so prevalent I want you to
at least be aware of them
and understand how
they relate to NPV.
And the last thing
I want to do is
to tell you about
the complexities
of financial decision
making by talking
about time as an element.
In other words, the
fact that decisions
are being made over
time makes these kinds
of interactions among projects
very, very complicated.
And I'm not going
to be able to solve
all of those for
you, that's what
15.434 of this course
on capital budgeting
and corporate financing will
do, but I want to give you
a taste of it so you
are aware that there
is a whole other
world out there where
you've got to take these
tools and understand
how to apply them.
OK.
So let's talk
about the NPV role.
We started this course
with a statement
that all assets are nothing more
than a sequence of cash flows.
That's what I call an asset.
Every single asset can
be reduced, essentially,
to a sequence of task flows.
So this is a sequence of cash
flows for a particular project,
or asset.
And the current
market value is simply
the NPV where now
you've got a discount
by the appropriate
cost of capital that
is an appropriate risk
adjusted cost of capital
where you are adjusting the
risk relevant to that particular
cash flow.
So you'll notice that I
use r1 for cash flow one,
and I use rT for cash T. What
that means is that you can have
two different discount
rates for two different cash
flows of the same
project because those two
different cash
flows may actually
have two different risks.
So now when you see this
expression, which is exactly
the same expression I showed
you at the very beginning
of this course, it should
have much more meaning to you
because now you understand
what amount of effort
goes in to coming up with that
appropriate discount rate.
It turns out that because
of something called value
additivity we can make
decisions about how
to allocate our resources
simply by picking those projects
with big positive NPVs.
In other words, you don't
have to worry about project
interactions unless
there are interactions
that are explicitly
involving your decisions.
Having a firm and
combining high NPV projects
is the best way to increase
the value of that firm.
So you look at each project
on a standalone basis
and if there are
project interactions
you then evaluate those
interactions separately,
and I'll give you
examples of that.
OK.
So we're all familiar with this.
This is just the
standard approach
to calculating market value.
Now, the investment
criteria that I'm
going to propose for
capital budgeting,
for project selection is this.
For a single project,
if you've got
one project you're
trying to decide upon,
take it if and only if
the NPV is positive.
If it's positive take
it, if it's negative
do not take it, or sell it.
Short it, if you can.
[LAUGHTER]
OK?
It's hard to short
projects it's not
that hard to short securities.
For many independent
projects, take all of them
with positive NPV.
If they're independent,
meaning that taking one
doesn't preclude you
from doing another,
or there's no
project interactions,
take them all as long as
they have positive NPV.
If there are project
interactions,
then you have to take
that into account.
So one simple example
of a project interaction
is you can only
take one of many.
And if that's the case,
then you pick the one
that's got the highest NPV.
Where you have to use the
proper risk adjustment
for that particular project.
So in order to compute
NPV you need three things,
you need cash flows, obviously,
you need the discount rates,
and you need to consider
strategic options.
The first and the third I'm
not going to help you with,
that's your business.
That's the business of business.
You've got to identify
what those cash flows are
and you've got to identify
what your options are.
What I could help you with,
in the context of this course,
is evaluating the market
value of those possibilities.
Those strategic options,
you now understand
how to use option
pricing analysis
and for discount
rates, you now know
how to use risk
adjustments to calculate
the appropriate discount rates.
But the other stuff is
domain specific expertise
that you bring to the table.
And so I told you at the
very beginning of the course
that finance is the language of
business, this is what I mean.
You can't even talk
about making a decision
unless you speak the
language of finance,
unless you evaluate projects
in this kind of a framework.
OK.
So in terms of cash
flow calculations,
I'm going to give you some
examples in a few minutes,
but let me summarize what
I'm going to tell you
and then we can talk about the
specifics through that example.
The first point, is you
should use cash flows, not
accounting earnings because
again, accounting earnings
are meant for purposes
other than decision making.
Accounting is really meant
as a kind of a checkup
to see how you've done.
How you've done is
not the same thing
as how you're going to do.
One of the things that I
think is apparently not
emphasized enough
is that when you
look at accounting
data you're looking
at numbers that are
not random variables,
they have been realized.
There's no uncertainty in what
a balance sheet, or an income
statement says.
It's about the past.
And accountants
hate uncertainties.
I don't know how many
people are accountants here,
or how many accountants you
know, but if you know them
you know there's a certain
personality type that gets
drawn into that profession.
And these are not
big risk takers,
they want to see order and
certainty in what they're
doing.
That's what a good
accountant will do,
is to try to understand
where to put all the expenses
and revenues into the proper
boxes so that it all adds up.
Accounting is incapable.
It is not designed to manage
and reflect uncertainty.
You've heard the term
off-balance sheet item, right?
For example, I've spoken
before about a credit default
swap, or a futures contract.
If you engage in a futures
transaction, the moment
you engage in that
transaction what's
the NPV of a futures contract?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
ANDREW LO: Zero.
Exactly.
And as a result, that does
not go on the balance sheet
because it is neither an
asset nor is it a liability.
It's both, or neither,
depending on how you look at it.
It's an off-balance sheet
item because it doesn't--
Where do you put it?
It has zero value.
But the point is that entering
into one of those agreements
has a big impact on
your future risk.
So accounting, the
language of accounting
is not ideally suited for
thinking about the future.
It's a wonderful method
for understanding
what happened in
the past and you
need to understand that in
order to plan for the future,
you need to know what
your current assets are
and what your current
liabilities are,
but that doesn't tell you where
your risks are going to be
and it doesn't
allow you to speak
about the dynamics of cash
flows because that's not
what an accountants job is.
That's not what accounting
is designed to do.
Right?
This is not meant to be
a critique of accounting,
but simply that you can't use
it for purposes that it wasn't
ideally designed to serve.
So the first point is,
you've got to use cash flows,
not accounting earnings.
Second point, you've got to
use after-tax cash flows.
Why?
Because you have to pay taxes.
That's one of the,
along with death
and some other unavoidable
aspects of life,
you have to pay taxes.
So if you have to pay
taxes, then you may as well
look at after-tax cash flows.
The reason this is
important is because there
are certain things that show up
as cash flows that you wouldn't
ordinarily think of as cash
flows because of the tax code.
For example, depreciation.
Depreciation is an
accounting technique
for attributing the
decline of capital assets.
When you buy a machine it's new
on day one, but after 50 years
it's not new anymore and
it's not worth the same
after 15 years as
it is on day one.
Now, how you account for the
loss in value of that machine,
how you account for how
the machine gets used up
over 15 years, that's a
matter of accounting practice
that may have no bearing
on the actual economics
of the machine, but it
has absolute bearing
on the cash flows
that you are going
to receive because you
get to deduct depreciation
expenses off of your taxes.
So after tax cash
flow is as important.
And finally, this third
point sounds simple,
but it's anything but simple
unless you practice with it
and do a lot of examples.
Use cash flows attributable
to the project.
In other words,
you've got to compare
the firm with and
without the project
and look at the cash flows.
OK?
It's very, very easy to forget
certain cash flows that either
come along with the
project, or have
to be spent if you
take on the project
and you'll end up missing
one element or another.
And in many cases those
kinds of omissions
can have a huge impact
on whether or not
you decide to take
on the project.
So there are lots of
examples about how
you might do that here, but
in the end practice, practice,
practice is going to
get you to understand
how to take into account
each of the features.
So I want to just go
through a few of these now
and then I'm going to
talk about the point
that I started
with earlier, which
is I want to show you some
techniques for capital
budgeting that are
incorrect and how
they relate to the NPV rule.
So let me just tell
you a little bit more
about accounting earnings
versus cash flows.
Cash flows are what you need
to use for calculating NPV
because in the end what matters
is the cash that you get,
not the accounting profits that
may or may not be realizable.
So cash flows are simply equal
to cash cash inflows minus cash
outflows.
That sounds simple, right?
It's not simple
because you've got
to figure out what those
cash inflows or outflows are
from, in many cases,
accounting data.
And so you need to
know a little bit
about how the
accounting interacts
with these kinds
of calculations.
So I'll just give you a
little bit more detail,
and I'll leave it up to you to
focus on specific applications
because the accounting
rules, first
of all they change fairly
often and actually right now
at the heart of the debate
in the financial crisis
is this notion of fair value
accounting, FAS 157, which
says that you've got to use
market values for updating
your assets and liabilities.
And that's a new ruling that
has created some problems
because market values,
during times of stress,
can drop precipitously.
And this is why I told you
early on that accounting
is not ideally suited to
deal with a lot of issues
having to do with risky
assets because risk is not
an element that the
accounting framework is
well-suited to deal with.
So how do we get cash
inflows minus cash outflows.
Well, operating
revenues is typically
what cash inflows involve for
a given project, operating
revenues.
And then, you subtract from
that operating expenses
without depreciation.
The reason you don't take
into account depreciation
is, as I told you,
depreciation is
one of these magic
accounting concepts that
has no bearing on reality.
It's a mechanism for
simply accounting
for a decline in the market
value of a particular kind
of equipment, or asset.
And there are a lot of
different accounting conventions
that are a function
of tax code changes.
For example, in some
cases you can accelerate
the depreciation of an asset.
Even though a machine
is working fine,
there are certain
situations where
you can assume that
half of the machine
evaporated after one year.
Now how does that happen?
Well it's an accounting tool
that Congress passed years
ago to allow companies,
businesses, to accelerate
the depreciation and
therefore get a tax advantage.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Aren't income taxes
linked to the accounting
nuances?
So if we're using
taxes, I'm saying,
sort of, we can't use
accounting [INAUDIBLE]
because it's a depreciation--
Depending what
depreciation that you
used, do income taxes change?
ANDREW LO: Yes.
That's right.
And so we're going to
take that into account,
but the point is that for
the purposes of cash flow,
the depreciation schedule
will impact the cash
flow only in terms of the actual
tax shields that it generates.
Not that it will decrease
the value of the machine
when the accountants
tell you that it will.
OK?
So the idea is that
your operating expenses
are expenses you have to
pay irrespective of what
the depreciation schedule is.
So accounting expenses
without depreciation
is what you're
paying out in cash.
It's the actual cash
outflow every single year.
Capital expenditures is what
you spend on new equipment,
and then income taxes.
So this is your point, Louis.
All of the effect of
depreciation on your income tax
gets included in here.
Income taxes you have
to pay every year,
so that's a cash outflow.
Right?
So if there's something that
can reduce your cash outflow,
you better take
that into account.
And that's where
depreciation comes in.
It's a tax shield that allows
you not to pay as much taxes,
so it reduces your tax burden,
it reduces your income taxes.
But again, the focus
is on cash flows.
Money in versus money out.
That's what you're
trying to measure.
And once you get the measure
of money in minus money out,
then you can start
discounting using
your appropriate
cost of capital,
but you got to get
the cash flows right.
And so there are a number
of other subtleties.
For example, the
project income taxes
that you pay for your project
is going to be the corporate tax
rate, times the operating
profit, minus the tax rate,
times your depreciation.
So your depreciation
doesn't actually
affect the profitability of the
particular piece of equipment,
or the project, except
in so far as it affects
the taxes you have to pay.
So project income taxes,
that income taxes associated
with your particular
project, are
going to simply be the tax rate
multiplied by the operating
profit, minus the tax rate,
times whatever depreciation
you can claim, and so this is
how you can get depreciation
into your cash flows.
It affects the amount of
income taxes you're paying
and that's it.
So the bottom line,
what's your task flow?
It's going to be one,
minus your tax rate,
times the operating profits.
Operating profits is operating
revenues, minus operating
expenses without depreciation.
Without depreciation.
Depreciation comes in later when
you're talking about the taxes.
So here is where the
depreciation comes in.
So your cash flow is
operating profits,
multiplied by one,
minus the tax rate,
minus your capital
expenditures, and by the way,
your capital expenditures,
notice that you're not
getting taxed on that.
Nor do you get a
deduction for that.
You don't get to deduct
capital expenditures the way
you get to deduct ordinary
expenses from running a company
because capital expenditures
are treated differently
by the tax code.
Does that make sense?
Who knows.
That's for the tax
experts to decide upon.
The fact is that capital
expenditures have
a different tax
treatment and you
have to know that, that's why
you need accountants to tell
you how they get treated.
The way they get treated is you
get to depreciate the capital
expenditures as the accountants
tell you you're using them up.
So if you buy a piece of
equipment for $25 million,
you don't get to deduct it
right away because you're not
using all of it right away.
You're using part
of it every year.
How much are you using?
That's where the depreciation
schedule becomes relevant.
So here what you're getting,
in terms of cash flows,
what you're getting
is the depreciation
that you report every year,
multiplied by the tax rate.
You're getting that as
a positive cash flow.
Why is that?
Who can tell me why that is?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because you're
not paying any expenses.
ANDREW LO: That's
not quite right.
It's along those lines, but
not exactly, that's not exactly
the mechanism.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: This
position is expense,
but it's not out of cash flow.
ANDREW LO: Right.
Depreciation is an
expense you get to deduct,
so you're right about
that, but you're
getting to deduct it purely
because of the tax code.
And because you get
to deduct it you
don't have to pay this much tax.
In other words, without
the depreciation
you would be out
this much money.
But because you
have that deduction,
it's like a get out
of jail free card,
you basically take
this card and say,
here I don't have to pay this
much tax, how much is that card
worth?
Well, it's worth this.
So this is actually
the amount of cash
you're going to get
to keep in your pocket
if you have this
depreciation tax shield.
That's what it's
called, a tax shield.
It prevents you from paying
a certain amount of taxes.
You actually get to keep
that money in your company.
So it's actual
cash flows to you.
So the accounting impact
of depreciation is here.
And it's important, I know it
seems like it's a waste of time
for us to spend time
for my telling you
how to do accounting, but this
is an important enough point
that people forget when you're
doing NPV calculations that I
want to hammer this home.
What matters, from an
economic perspective,
is the cash that you're
getting for your project
year in and year out.
Keep your eyes on the cash.
Don't keep it on the accounting
numbers, keep it on the cash.
And if you do that,
you'll never go wrong.
OK.
Here's an example just
to make the point.
A machine is purchased for a $1
million with a life of 10 years
and it generates annual
revenues of 300,000
and operating
expenses of 100,000.
If you assume that
the machine gets
depreciated over 10 years using
straight line depreciation.
What does that
mean, straight line?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Equal
amounts every year.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
So if the machine is
worth a million bucks
and you're depreciating it
over 10 years straight line,
what do you deduct every year?
AUDIENCE: 1,000 [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: 100,000.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
It'd be 100 years
if you did 10,000.
That would be a long
life of the machine.
That's right $10,000--
$100,000 a year
for 10 years, that's how much
the accountants are telling you
you're using up the machine.
And so every year you
get to deduct $100,000
from that kind of depreciation.
So what is your
after-tax cash flow?
Now, you're accounting
earnings, the way
that an accountant would accrue
the earnings would be this.
It's 3 million, minus
100k, minus a 300k,
minus 100k, minus 100k,
that's 100k of earnings.
So an accountant would
tell you that your earnings
for this situation
is $100,000 a year.
Right?
However, that's
not the cash flows.
Let's look at the task flows.
The cash flows on
an after tax basis,
assuming a 40% corporate
tax rate is 1 minus 0.4,
times revenue of 300, minus
operating expenses of 100.
So you're making $200 cash
every year before tax,
but then you've got to
pay tax, but then you're
getting a depreciation
deduction of $100,000 a year.
So you're actually getting
$160,000 of cash every year.
Not a 100, but 160.
So when you do an
NPV calculation
it makes a world of difference
whether your NPVing this guy,
or your NPVing this guy.
They're not the same.
Right?
And from an economic
decision perspective,
this is what you ought
to focus on, not on this.
Yeah, Edward?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Probably through the
accounting calculation,
you will have the
million up front.
While here you will have a
cash flow and a cash in flow
from here [INAUDIBLE], right?
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In the accounting.
ANDREW LO: That's right.
So there are other
considerations
that you might want to
bring into the analysis,
but my point is simply
using accounting earnings
versus after tax cash flows will
give you a different number.
In both cases, I'm not I'm
not taking into account
the upfront outlay of a million.
Right?
AUDIENCE: But in the
accounting you would never.
ANDREW LO: Right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Agreed.
That's right.
And that's part of the problem.
That's one of the
reasons, by the way,
why certain companies
are incentivized
to acquire other companies.
It's because the
acquisition costs
aren't accounted for in the same
way that the operating costs.
So if you've got
a company that's
generating a lot of profits,
it's very profitable,
but it cost you a lot of money
to acquire, from the counting
perspective it can
make you look really
good because your earnings
are going to get a big boost,
but in fact the NPV
of the situation
may not be as attractive.
The bottom line from
shareholder wealth,
if you are doing this for
your own personal account
you'd want to be
making decisions
not on accounting earnings
alone, but rather on cash
flows.
All right?
NPVs.
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: What about if you
can give a working capital?
Aren't you supposed to take
it also in to consideration?
ANDREW LO: In what sense?
You're looking at the
net incremental impact
on your working capital and
this take that into account.
Wokring capital is the change--
is demanding opportunity
to invest in the business
in order to make the
business to grow.
ANDREW LO: Yeah, that's right.
So I haven't talked
about what the NPV.
Is if you want to do the NPV
you've got to ask the question,
does the after tax cash flow
justify a million dollars?
I haven't talked about that yet.
So I'm not I'm not
suggesting that we've
got an answer for
what you should
do with this
particular situation,
I'm simply using this
as an illustration
to point out that
accounting earnings is not
the same thing as after
tax net cash task flows.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So from a
finance [INAUDIBLE] point,
we don't care about this
[INAUDIBLE] company, as well as
this ability to generate
future cash flows?
ANDREW LO: Well, no I
didn't I did not say that.
The question about
whether or not
you care about the
solvency of the company
is a question about what the
ultimate costs of bankruptcy
are, but from a
shareholder's perspective,
if you ask the question what
does the shareholder want
you, the corporate manager,
to do, the answer is simple.
The shareholder wants you to
maximize the net present value
of the business.
OK?
If there are dramatic
costs of bankruptcy,
or financial stress,
then you're going
to have to incorporate that
into your calculation for what
you should do.
Absolutely.
But the point is
that when you're
looking at net present value,
net present value gives you
the appropriate data
to make that trade off.
Always use net present
value to at least calculate
the implications of the
various different investments.
In the case of bankruptcy
costs, if there
are dramatic costs of
financial distress,
then you don't want to go
there because then you're
not going to be serving the best
interest of the shareholders.
But if on the other hand,
there are very little risks
of financial
distress and there's
an incredibly good
opportunity for you
to take on certain risk that
looks more than worthwhile
relative to the
compensation you're getting,
then I would argue that
it makes sense to do so.
So the question is
one about magnitude.
What are the bankruptcy
costs versus the value
of the upside for the
particular project at hand?
And you've got to
make that decision
with all the various different
data properly computed.
What I'm telling you how to
do is to compute that data.
All right.
Here are some other
calculations that describe
what went on in the previous.
This is a case of accounting
earnings after tax, cash flow
after tax.
The bottom line is
that they're different.
So for the perspective
of NPV calculations
you ought to focus on the
particular calculation that
gives you net cash flows.
So now I'm going to turn to
focusing on the denominator,
discount rates.
We already went through
an analysis about how
to pick the discount rate.
The discount rate that
you use is the one
that adjusts for the
risk of the project,
but keep in mind that
a project's discount
rate, the required
rate of return
is the expected return demanded
by investors for the project.
The way you ought to think
about it is the project,
think of it like a stock and
ask the question, for people who
are going to buy
that project, they're
going to buy the stock,
what kind of a discount rate
are they going to place on
the riskiness of that stock.
It's just like Gillette
versus General Motors,
we talked about that last time.
Depending on how risk
averse the population is,
that will determine a
particular market risk premium.
The market risk
premium and the beta
is going to determine what the
appropriate discount rate is
for that particular stock,
and the idiosyncratic risk
is going to be assumed
away because nobody
has to bear that risk.
Everybody can be diversified
if they want to be.
The second thing is that the
discount rate, in general,
depends on the timing and
the risks of the cash flows.
I'm going to give you an
example in a few minutes that'll
throw you off a
bit because there's
going to be two
different kinds of risks
and you're going to have to
differentiate between the two.
So let me come
back to that point
with an example that
will be much clearer.
And the last couple of points
is that, the discount rate
is usually different
for different projects.
Now, this is something
that, again, a lot
of corporate managers miss.
They feel that if they're in
a particular division then
that division has a
particular cost of capital
and from that point
on you should always
use the cost of
capital for anything
that the division does.
What if it's the case
that the division is
doing something so different
from what it originally
started with?
And I'm going to give
you an example of that.
An example is something that
happened just a couple of years
ago.
I don't know how
many of you realize,
but Bloomberg, you know the
maker of those nice terminals
that everybody uses, Bloomberg
has actually a publishing
company.
Yeah that's right.
There's a Bloomberg
Business press.
They publish books and this
particular business just
got launched a
couple of years ago.
They already have a
whole bunch of books.
In fact, they're
publishing a book
that I've been working on
with a former student of mine
a series of interviews
of technical analysts.
And so as part of this idea of
setting up a business press,
they had to figure out what
the appropriate cost of capital
is for that activity, and then
ask for money from the parent
company to launch this.
So the question is,
how do they do that?
Do they use the appropriate
cost of capital for Bloomberg?
Bloomberg's business
is not publishing.
All right?
They're an information
vendor, and they're
a technology company.
And as such, they have a
certain multiple, right?
Those of you who are in venture
capital, project financing,
you know about multiples, right?
If you have a company with a
particular kind of earnings,
then the value of the
company is typically
stated as a multiple
of those earnings.
The multiple for an IT
company, a technology company,
a financial services
company, a multiple
there is not the
same as the multiple
for a publishing company.
By the way, which
multiple is higher?
Does anybody know?
AUDIENCE: IT?
ANDREW LO: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Actually,
publishing is higher.
ANDREW LO: Multiple for
publishing is higher?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I think
it would be higher unless
it's [INAUDIBLE] particular--
ANDREW LO: And why is that?
What's the logic
for IT being higher?
AUDIENCE: Higher
growth potential.
ANDREW LO: Higher growth
potential, that's one.
Also, profit margins
tend to be higher.
Publishing is not
a growing business.
I don't know how many
of you realize that.
Because of the internet,
because of text messaging,
all sorts of
innovations have really
hurt the publishing business.
And that's why a
lot of publishers
have either gone out of
business or have combined,
so that now we have a
few mega publishers.
Yeah.
So if you're an
entrepreneur that's
looking to set up
Bloomberg Press
and now Bloomberg is using a
particular cost of capital,
you may say, "Well, hey,
wait a minute, that's
not the right cost of
capital because publishing
is a different multiple."
How would you do that, then?
How would you figure
out what to use in order
to calculate the value of a
venture for Bloomberg Press?
Courtney?
AUDIENCE: Just look at
the comparable companies
and take, like, look at all
the betas of all of them,
and do analysis from them.
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
So let's look at other companies
that are in the business
that we want to get into and
see what kind of beta they have,
and what the appropriate
cost of capital is.
Anant?
AUDIENCE: So I understand
why they doing that.
But at the end of the day, if
Bloomberg, the company, has,
you know, $1 million or
whatever to invest, why would it
look at going into an area
like this with a lower
rate of return than, you
know, a product where it could
get a high rate of return?
Unless you have some facilities,
in which case facilities plus
rate of return should be
at least equal to the rate
of return for the economy.
ANDREW LO: So let's hold off on
that discussion for a moment.
I'm not going to try to
justify why they get into it,
I just want to
understand the mechanics
of how they decide on whether
or not to get into it.
I'll come back to why later.
Let's come back to that in
just a few minutes though.
Before we get to
that, let's figure out
how they even evaluate.
All right?
So I've suggested here
that they might use
the beta of John Wiley & Sons.
That's a publicly-traded
publishing company.
But they could also use
the beta of McGraw-Hill.
Which should we pick?
McGraw-Hill or John Wiley?
Louis?
AUDIENCE: John Wiley.
ANDREW LO: Why?
AUDIENCE: Because McGraw-Hill's
not a pure play publisher.
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
McGraw-Hill has lots of other
businesses besides publishing.
So while they do do
a lot of publishing,
they also do a lot
of other things.
Give me another business that
McGraw-Hill is involved in it.
Anybody?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Standard & Poor's?
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
McGraw-Hill owns
Standard & Poor's.
And Standard & Poor's does a lot
of things, including publishing
ratings as well as indexes.
So those businesses are not
the same as publishing books.
McGraw-Hill has lots
of other subsidiaries,
whereas John Wiley & Sons,
all they do is publishing.
They are what is known
as a pure play company.
So let's take a look.
This is the revenues of
John Wiley & Sons in 2007.
If you look at the
core business--
39% professional trade, 70%
higher ed, 44% scientific,
technical, and medical--
that's not a perfect
match for Bloomberg,
but that's not bad, right?
That's within the
same general area.
What we would really prefer
is if it were just this slice
that we could carve
out and figure out
what that business looked like.
But that's not so easy
to do because of the fact
that it's one company
that's doing all of it.
Ken?
AUDIENCE: How much
does size matter?
How much should Bloomberg
take into consideration
the fact that John Wyley
is [INAUDIBLE] doing it
at a different scale?
ANDREW LO: Well, so I guess I
would be lying if I told you
that size didn't matter.
That's usually the case.
Size matters in
the sense that you
want to have a company
that's representative
of what you're trying to do.
And smaller companies bear
certain risks that larger
companies don't.
And vice versa, larger companies
have access to certain benefits
and technologies that
smaller companies don't.
So the point is
that we don't always
get to choose what's available.
You've got to look at the
various different alternatives
out there and the best way to
approach it is to get a range.
So if you're going
to be doing this
in a more serious
fashion, what you do
is to make a study of
the publishing business.
Find companies at both
ends of the spectrum.
The small ones and the
big ones, the pure plays
and the conglomerates,
and estimate
the cost of capital
for all of them.
And then say, given this
spectrum of results,
we think that the appropriate
cost of capital should be here.
And basically make a
choice after having
looked at the evidence.
So what I'm giving you
is not a simple recipe
that will work in
every circumstance
but rather an approach
that, with sufficient study
and analysis, will yield
an intelligent answer.
So let's actually take a look
at the answer here, all right?
So we've got John
Wiley & Sons, we've
got their performance over a
period of time, the share price
and so on.
If you take the beta of John
Wiley & Sons series A shares,
and you can get that from
Yahoo, it's a beta of 1.29 as
of last year.
Then, with a risk-free rate of
5% and a market-risk premium
of 6%--
which is when
Bloomberg was trying
to decide when to go into the
business, about two years ago--
it turns out that the
cost of capital is 12.7%.
So that's actually a
pretty reasonable cost
of capital, which
says that that's
the number you use in
figuring out whether or not
the cash flows from a
publishing business make sense.
OK?
Now to Anant's
question, why on earth
would you do that
when you could invest
in a business that may have
a higher cost of capital
or a higher rate of return?
We don't know that they do.
In other words, at
this point, Bloomberg
may not have any
ability to invest
in its current
business or others that
have a higher rate of return.
So one could argue that a
cost of capital of about 12.7%
is actually a pretty reasonable
hurdle rate for a new business.
So in other words, I would
only invest in this business
if it yielded a positive NPV.
Now a positive NPV means
it's earning more than 12.7%
on average, right?
That's a pretty good rate of
return for a new business.
Now, there is another
business that Bloomberg
could get into which is the
hedge fund business, right?
I mean, why not?
They've got all this data,
they may as well make use of it
and turn into a hedge fund.
Now, that business, I suspect
that the cost of capital
is a lot higher.
Higher because the riskiness
is more substantial.
And there, you have to start
talking about the riskiness
of bankruptcy.
Would it really be a
good idea to jeopardize
Bloomberg's entire franchise
on one mega hedge fund?
I don't know, maybe?
But probably not,
if you really are
serious about preserving the
franchise value the company.
Mike?
AUDIENCE: So then,
to that point,
how do you consider the impact
on the rest of Bloomberg,
given this
additonal-- if they go
into this additional division?
ANDREW LO: Well, so that's
the project interactions
that I haven't talked about.
Up until now, I'm assuming this
is a standalone subsidiary.
And I'm evaluating it
as positive NPV or not.
OK?
The next step in the
capital budgeting process
is to then ask the question,
OK, as a standalone entity,
I think I understand it.
I got the cash flows down, I
got the discount rate down.
I know what the comparisons are.
I've evaluated the NPV
and it looks positive.
Now let me ask, what does this
do strategically for the firm?
That's the third question,
the strategic options.
Is it good?
Or is it not so good?
And if so can I put
a number on that?
Now, from Bloomberg, I wasn't
involved in any discussions
internally so I can't tell you
what Bloomberg came up with.
But from what I
gather, they decided
that there are some positive
synergies between a business
press and their other
media type of access.
That they felt that there
were some cross-selling
opportunities so that,
when there was a good book,
they could put it on
the Bloomberg screen
and advertise free, basically.
And then the print
media would actually
help to support
attention to Bloomberg
as an outlet for news.
So in that case, they determined
that this interaction was all
good, that there wasn't
a downside to it.
And part of the
reason, I think, is
because they were
able to assemble
a team of very experienced
publishers and editors.
They pulled them out of
other publishing firms
to start this new
venture, and they ended up
getting some really
good people involved.
And I've had the pleasure
to work with some of them.
They are very,
very professional.
So Bloomberg actually made a
pretty good decision, at least
from the perspective of
getting this thing launched.
Whether or not it will
be profitable, who knows?
It's only been around
for a couple of years,
but so far they've developed
a pretty impressive list
of authors.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I guess
what I'm saying--
Let's just say the
rest of Bloomberg
had a cost of capital of 10.
They go to this, let's say
it pulls everything up to 11.
The rest of their business
is now more expensive.
That was more my question.
Will we include the
value of destruction
on the rest of their business
for raising their overall cost?
ANDREW LO: Well, so--
If there's any kind of value
creation or destruction,
you're implicitly assuming some
kind of market irrationality.
Right?
Because what you're assuming is
that, if they pull this thing
up, they pull up the cost of
capital for the entire firm,
they lower the valuation
of the entire firm.
You're assuming that
people in the industry
can't see through the fact
that they've got a subsidiary.
And in some cases,
you may be right.
But I would argue that
a better perspective is
to say that analysts
are going to be
able to do
division-by-division valuation
and say, OK, they got
a publishing division.
These are the revenues,
these are the costs,
they're segregated, and
it makes sense for them,
given the synergies.
Blah, blah, blah.
So I would expect that
those considerations may not
be as significant.
Now if, on the other hand,
this publishing operation
were really big--
In other words, if it ended
up that it grew so big that it
accounted for half of the
revenues of Bloomberg,
the entity, then I think your
point would be well taken,
would be much more serious.
Right now, it's a
tiny, little blip
in the grand scheme
of things that
may turn into something big.
But for example, if you're
an investment bank--
Nowadays, we don't have any
more of those but at one point
we did.
If you're an investment bank
and you've got a franchise based
upon customer-driven
business, very reliable,
very high multiples, very, very
valuable kind of franchise--
And then the question
is, should you
get involved in prop trading?
Prop trading,
proprietary trading,
basically being a
hedge fund, carries
in the marketplace no multiple.
Actually in some cases,
the multiple is negative,
I mean, that is, less than 1.
Right?
Because if you're thinking
about acquiring a hedge fund,
the typical hedge
fund will provide you
with whatever earnings
they have this year,
but next year they
could blow up.
So there is no multiple assigned
to hedge funds, typically.
Not always.
I can give you examples over
the last couple of years where
hedge funds have
sold for multiples,
but there are not many of them.
And typically, a
hedge fund, when
you look at the value of the
future earnings, the multiple
that is applied
can be less than 1
if there is a concern that
the hedge fund can drag down
the value of the parent company.
So there are situations
where, for a distress sale,
people have paid $0.50 on the
dollar of assets of a hedge
fund.
Of the actual cash that the
hedge fund has generated
for its shareholders,
they've paid
less than a dollar for dollar
because of that kind of effect
on the parent company.
Goldman Sachs, after
they went public,
they really had a lot of
difficulty internally,
thinking about prop trading,
because prop trading accounted
during certain years for such
a large fraction of the Goldman
franchise that it ended
up having the effect
that Mike was talking about.
That is, people said,
gee, Goldman is nothing
but a prop trading firm.
I'm not going to give
it a multiple of seven.
Let's try a multiple
of 2 and 1/2.
That is value destruction.
That's a concern.
But for small
projects that aren't
about the entire
corporation, that
aren't likely to
affect the perception
of the entire corporation, you
don't have to worry about that.
So size does matter
in another way.
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: How did
you with, like,
[INAUDIBLE] and risk-free rate?
So today what rate
would be used?
ANDREW LO: Today I'd use 1%.
So this is the time element
that I mentioned to you before.
When you take on
a project, you've
got to have the right time.
It's got to be the right time.
And so things change.
The cost of capital changes.
So right now, I would use 1%
for this particular project.
So you might think
it'd be easier
to get it launched,
but try getting cash
in a setting like today.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you
start a project,
say it's a two-year project
and you start it at 1%,
and then all of a sudden
the risk-free rate goes up.
Does that mean that you
might, economically,
need to cancel your
project halfway through?
ANDREW LO: Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
At one point, John
Maynard Keynes
was criticized for flip
flopping on the gold standard
and Keynes had a very, very
sensible reply, which I think
I may have mentioned in class.
Which is that, when the facts
change, sir, I change my mind.
What do you do?
So absolutely.
If cost of capital
changes a year from now,
you may have to
cancel your project.
Or you may wish you had
taken two of the projects,
but you didn't get to.
These kinds of project
interactions over time
make it really complicated.
That's one of the reasons why
we have a whole separate course
on capital budgeting,
is to come up
with tools to deal with
these kind of interactions.
So absolutely.
In fact, I'm going to
give an example of that
in just a minute where
that time element actually
is very important.
Let's actually go
over that right now.
So here's an example that
you don't know how to do yet.
We're going to figure out
how to do it together.
All right?
And it has to do with
time and with risks.
So a firm is investing in
an oil exploration project.
We're going to drill a bunch
of holes in a particular area
where I'm trying to find oil.
And it's going to take
time to drill these holes.
So it's going to
take at least a year.
And at the end of
the first year,
there's going to be
a probability of 1/3
that we find three
million barrels of oil.
But there's a probability
of 2/3 that we find nothing,
we come up dry.
1/3, 2/3 probability.
Now, if we are successful with
that 1/3 probability, then
the 3 million
barrels of oil will
be pumped out of the ground
by the end of the second year.
So at the end of the first
year, if we're successful,
we'll find oil.
And then it'll take a year
to extract it and barrel it.
Put it in barrels and sell it.
And we'll have 3
million barrels to be
able to do that,
and then after that,
the field will be depleted.
Now the expected after-tax
profit per barrel is $20.
We're going to make
$20 a barrel after-tax.
Not now, but a year from now.
The risk-free rate is 5%.
The industry discount rate
of oil production is 20%.
That's a very high
cost of capital.
But oil production is
a high beta activity,
as you can sort of tell, right?
Market prices are down.
Oil prices down.
When the market was up, oil
prices were pretty high.
Oil has a high beta, OK?
So the discount rate is 20%,
but the exploration risk--
this 1/3, 2/3 probability--
that has a beta of 0.
What's the NPV of this project?
How do you figure that out?
Believe it or not, you
actually have all the tools
to solve this problem.
But it's hard.
And not only is it
hard for all of you,
it's actually hard
for professionals.
A couple of years ago, I taught
the Sloan Fellows program
during the summer.
I don't know how much you know
about the Sloan Fellows program
but this is a program where
we bring executives who've
worked for 15, 20, 30
years, made their fortunes,
and have decided to take a
year off to get a degree.
And so these are very
seasoned, senior professionals,
so teaching them is a
whole other challenge.
They're very-- they know a lot.
And they know a lot
about virtually anything
and everything you ever
care to talk about.
To case in point,
I gave this example
to the Sloan Fellows class.
Somebody in the back of
the room said, "Excuse me.
First, Lo, but I don't
recall that we actually used
this analysis when we were
doing oil exploration."
And I said, well, why don't
you tell us about what you did,
and who you are, and so on.
And the fellow said, "Well,
I'm the senior vice-president
for oil exploration
at Saudi Aramco."
This is the biggest oil
company in the world,
and he was the man in charge
of drilling those holes.
And he actually said that
they didn't do this analysis,
but that he actually
was going to try it out
because he thought it
made a lot of sense.
So that was a little
scary, I have to tell you.
A very intimidating audience.
But the point is that this
is a very subtle idea.
Let me tell you what it is.
Let me tell you
how it works, OK?
There are two risks
going on here.
There is the market risk
of pumping the oil out
of the ground and selling it.
And that we
understand quite well.
That has a beta given by this
particular cost of capital,
20%.
So we already know
what the discount rate
is in that second year.
But we need to figure out how
to discount from the second year
to the first year.
What should the appropriate
risk-adjusted discount rate
is from the first year
back to year zero.
That's the key.
Right?
That's the hard part.
At the end of the
second year, we're
going to have 3
million barrels of oil,
each priced at $20 a barrel for
a profit of $60 million, right?
Or $6 million here.
Yeah.
So $60 million at
the end of two years.
Now we're going to
discount it back
to the beginning of
that two year period.
So in other words, we're
going to discount it
from the end of the second
year to the beginning
of that second year, or
the end of the first year,
and that's what we get
as $50 million, right?
$60 million discounted
back by 20% discount rate,
that's $50 million at year
one, if we strike oil.
But there's a 1/3 probability
that we strike oil.
There's a 2/3 probability
that we don't.
The question is, what do we
discount this possibility back
to year zero?
And I'm going to argue you
discount it back, not at 20%
but at 5%.
5%?
That's the risk-free rate.
Now, why on earth
would you do that?
This is the oil industry
we're talking about.
The reason you discount the
first year back to year zero
at risk-free rate is because
the risk of coming up dry,
that risk is completely
diversifiable.
That is complete,
idiosyncratic risk.
There is no beta, right?
The oil deposits
underground don't
know whether it's a bull
market or a bear market.
They couldn't care less.
They're either there
or they're not there,
and you're drilling for it.
So your risk of not striking oil
has no bearing on the market.
If you are well
diversified, then that risk
is actually not
something that you're
going to get rewarded for.
And therefore, you
need to discount it
at the risk-free rate.
So in fact, the NPV of this
project is $15.9 million,
which is a lot bigger number
than if you were to discount it
by 20% both years.
But it's because the
risks are different.
So to Brian's point, when
risk changes over time,
you've got to use the
appropriate discount
rate for that
particular kind of risk.
Now, it just so happens that
here ahead of time, we actually
understood where the
risks were coming from.
So we know the risks between
year zero and year one
are different from the risks
between year one and year two.
You've got to use the
appropriate discount
rate for that kind of risk.
This is a very subtle
problem that you
have to think about carefully
in order to understand it fully.
But it's an important one so
that's why I spent time on it.
Any questions about this?
Any debate?
Any argument?
Do you agree with this?
Does this make sense to you?
If it doesn't make
sense, speak up now
or forever hold your peace.
Right?
Because it's important
that you absorb the lesson
from this particular example.
Yeah, Andy?
AUDIENCE: So suppose that
you know for a fact there's
a third of 20 million
barrels in the ground.
You consider the same project?
That has the exact same--
ANDREW LO: That's right.
AUDIENCE: --value?
Absolutely.
Because there, you
have no uncertainty.
And you're just simply
taking the expected value
and assuming that you're
getting the expected value.
And it's because the
uncertainty of this project
in the first year is
completely diversifiable.
It's a coin flip.
And you're not going
to get rewarded
for bearing that coin flip
because, if you diversify--
Put it another way.
Suppose you were Saudi Aramco
and, instead of doing one
of these fields, you did 100?
Well, then you've
diversified across all sorts
of possible coin flips, and
then the law of large numbers
would actually reduce your
payoff to something very, very
riskless, or close to riskless.
Right?
Ted?
AUDIENCE: Would you
just restate again
why the first year is
at 5% as opposed to 20%?
ANDREW LO: Sure.
The first year is the 5%
because I told you here
that the exploration risk is
completely non-systematic.
It's zero beta.
So when you're drilling
for holes, whether or not
you find oil or
you don't find oil
has absolutely no bearing
on whether the market is
up or down.
There's no correlation.
If there's no
correlation, then that
means that it's a kind
of risk that you're not
going to get rewarded for.
This is the Irish jig
dance-- you know, the dancing
on that platform.
You're not going to get
paid extra for dancing
an Irish jig on that platform
when you're window washing.
OK?
So the key here is this
statement right here.
The exploration risk
is non-systematic.
If the exploration risk were
systematic for any reason, then
of course, you'd have
to use a discount
rate that would be commensurate
with the appropriate beta.
And there's no
telling that that beta
is going to be the same
as pumping the oil out.
Oil exploration is not the
same thing as oil production.
There are two different
kinds of activities
that carry with it
different kinds of risks.
OK?
Other questions or comments?
Yeah?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: How often does
this happen in practice?
I mean, most of the time
during my experience,
we would forecast that 15
or 20 years down the line.
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Most of the time
we would pick a discount
rate that, you know, tries to--
It's a level discount rate.
We're not going to, you
know, try and change
that discount rate.
ANDREW LO: Right.
AUDIENCE: It could be 10 year--
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
So the answer is, it
depends on the industry.
For certain industries where
you cannot identify discrete
changes in the riskiness
of the activities,
then it makes sense.
The only thing you can do is to
come up with one discount rate.
But for industries
like this where
there are discrete phases
of these different projects,
then you actually do use
different discount rates.
Because the uncertainty
resolves in a different manner,
depending on the industry.
So if you keep in
mind the lesson
that the appropriate
discount rate should
be commensurate with the risks
of that particular cash flow--
Think of each cash flow
as a piece of paper
that you're auctioning off
to people in a marketplace.
And ask the question, what would
those folks in the marketplace
demand in terms of the
appropriate compensation
for that kind of risk?
You'll be able to make
the right decisions.
OK?
And if you can't tell,
then you may as well
use one discount rate.
If you can't tell one
cash flow from another,
then what you're telling me
is that, effectively, it's
the same kind of project.
OK.
We're out of time.
I wish you all a
Happy Thanksgiving.
We'll see you on
Monday where we're
going to continue on
with capital budgeting
and do some more applications.